una noche ansiada por los fanáticos del
parís saint germain y los fieles de leo
messi el debut oficial del astro
argentino como nueva figura del club de
la capital francesa el psc dominó al
staff de hans en la cuarta jornada de la
liga a 2 a 0 leo vio la primera mitad
del partido desde el banco salió al
terreno en el minuto 66 como reemplazo
de neymar y fue recibido por una ovación
como era de esperar no hizo mucho pero
se le vio cómodo en varias jugadas
ofensivas con su joven compañero william
mbappe los primeros pasos del séxtuple
balón de oro junto a la armada parisina
fueron seguidos con emoción por la
fanaticada un furor que quizás se
describe mejor con cifras más de 20.500
entradas vendidas en un abrir y cerrar
de ojos algunas en hasta mil euros en el
mercado no oficial cerca de 150 medios
de comunicación acreditados al menos 52
de ellos transmitiendo en vivo para todo
el planeta 29 de agosto de 2021 una
fecha para recordar el inicio en el
terreno de este nuevo capítulo en la
carrera de leonel messi como estrella